[MUSIC]
Silicon Valley is the new American dream.
It's where companies are born,
and millionaires are made.
Like many of you,
I was part of that dream.
Before coming to the GSB,
I was an Executive at Cisco, and
then went on to work for
Adventure Back Startup.
I'd like to start with
a much simpler dream.
The dream of my grandparents.
Antonio Nicolasa.
They dreamt of running water,
electricity, and indoor plumbing.
Things they didn't have in
their small village in Mexico.
So they moved to the United States,
and search of a better life.
Where they became migrant farm workers
who harvested the fields right here
in Silicon Valley, before it
became Google, Apple and Facebook.
But as you know, the fields disappeared.
And when that happened,
my family transitioned to roles to
provide the backbone of this valley.
The people who clean your homes.
The people who take out your trash.
And the people who even
take care of your children.
One morning before school, I got up really
early to go with my grandparents to work.
I walked into the bathroom to
help my grandmother clean, and
I'd never seen such a mess before.
My grandmother saw the look on my face.
And she explained how
important this job was,
that it would allow us to
put food on the table.
She encouraged me to
take pride in my work,
to make that bathroom as sparkling
clean as I could make it.
My grandmother,
who had a fourth grade education,
taught me that day to approach each and
every task with dignity and with grit.
In Silicon Valley, venture capitalists
are in search of the next billion dollar
startup, the elusive unicorn.
Well, people from my neighborhood,
we have a very different
definition of what a unicorn is.
I grew up in East San Jose,
about 20 miles south of here.
When I think of home, I think of
my grandmother's yellow kitchen.
I think of the scent of
her homemade tortillas.
And I think of the sounds
of Mariachi music.
As a little girl, I loved to play outside.
And one day, I managed to sneak
out when no one was looking and
was happily playing in the garden.
When out of the corner of my eye,
I saw my grandmother running towards me.
She scooped me in her arms, and
like many Mexican grandmothers
scolded me in Spanish, and
then made the sign of the cross.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You see,
my grandmother knew that although
our neighborhood was very beautiful,
it could also be very dangerous.
It meant walking home from school and
having a gun pulled on you.
It meant being peer
pressured to join a gang.
It meant having a baby,
when you were a baby.
My family wasn't immuned to this, sadly.
And of my 20 cousins,
only 10 graduated from high school,
and only 3 of us would go on
to graduate from college.
This isn't unique to my family, but
is happening to Latino
families across the country.
Latinos with college degrees,
these are the unicorns.
In Silicon Valley,
technology has been booming all around us.
It's been creating tremendous opportunity
and wealth, it's been exciting.
And my family has been able to take
part of the little piece of it.
My younger brother Rikko is one
of the smartest guys I know.
It would really frustrate me when I was
stuck on my physics homework assignment,
and he would manage to
solve it effortlessly.
He's the kind of guy who loved to take
things apart, and put them back together.
He was a natural engineer.
My brother is also a high school dropout.
And he became a dad when
he was 17 years old.
My brother was able to turn his
life around, to go back to school.
And find a job working in manufacturing
for a local tech company.
Because of that opportunity,
he was able not only to provide for
his family but also for me.
And one summer,
my brother gave me his paychecks,
so that I could live in Paris and
study at the Sorbonne.
That simple act of generosity,
and love from a different track,
it's the reason that I'm
here with all of you.
But even with that college degree,
my path to career and technology.
With very different in the part that
many of you took, it was a hustle.
I worked at three different temporary
agencies before I landed that first job
at Cisco.
And I will never forget receiving that
offer letter, and being so excited.
Not only what it meant for me,
but what it meant for my family.
But the bubble burst.
The manufacturing jobs went away.
My brother lost his job.
Other people in my family lost their jobs.
My parents couldn't afford the home
anymore, so they looked to me,
the one with the good job, to help.
That entry level salary at Cisco,
barely covered a third of their mortgage.
So my parents moved to central California,
back to the fields, where it all began.
The Silicon Valley dream?
It was out of reach for them.
While this area has been
growing at record phase.
Communities like east San Jose have been
suffering one setback after the other.
Loss of jobs, loss of homes and
lack of upward mobility.
This isn't just my problem.
It's our problem.
Latinos represent one of the fastest
growing groups in the country.
This is expected to project
a $1.5 trillion opportunity.
Think about that.
I bet you didn't know that Latinos have
this beautiful entrepreneurial spirit.
They start businesses at record rate.
Within my family alone, there have been
five business that have been started.
So why, if Latinos are starting
businesses at record rate.
Why are we able to capitalize on them?
Professor here at the GSP,
has been setting this
very phenomenon as part of the Standford
Latino Entrepreneurship Initiative.
And one of the things
that he's discovered,
is Latinos lack access to mentors.
As one of the few people from my
neighborhood who had a career in
technology, I knew how
important it was to go back.
So I went to the schools I attended and
volunteered.
I hosted events at local libraries.
I even started a small scholarship fund.
Through this work, I met Carlos.
Carlos had just finished his
freshman year at Harvard.
When I asked Carlos what his
plans were for the summer.
He looked at me and said that he was
going to work construction with his dad.
When I asked, Carlos,
have you thought of an internship?
He said, I would love an internship,
but I have no idea where to begin.
Carlos was one of the lucky ones.
I wanted the leading
institutions in this country.
And yet, even he was struggling to
navigate this business landscape.
I knew how that felt.
But more importantly, I knew how
to help them find that internship.
People like Carlos may not
have the polished resume.
They may not have the pedigree.
But what do they have, is dignity,
grit, and their entrepreneurial spirit.
What they're missing, is opportunity.
So, what I'd like to ask
each of you is that,
you either are,
all will become leaders in business.
In this valley and across the world.
Please look again at people
from a different path.
Hire them, mentor them.
Imagine the impact that all of
us could have on communities
like east San Jose,
if we add opportunity to the equation.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]